hey guys this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so i'm a professional
trader for six years now
in hong kong and i've worked for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank
and i've started to make some youtube
videos two months ago
where i try to share with you guys all
my experience and show you how we
actually work
in a professional environment i heard a
lot of euphoria coming from the reddit
forum for example
and those guys they basically think that
they can make money in the long run just
by
buying hot stocks well i don't think
it's going to work
i think that ultimately so maybe they're
making some money right now but most of
them
most of them are going to get wiped out
and those who are going to make money
ultimately are actually
professionals so i'm here guys to pass
the information you know
so to show you how actually
professionals are working
so today i want to show you the whole
process of analyzing
for me for example i'm going to talk
about the ripple and other
cryptocurrencies because i know that you
guys very interested into this hot
cryptos and i'm gonna show you how i
build up my view and set up my treads
from scratch let's get into it
[Music]
so i do this video for my friend anthony
who has
actually some dutch coin some bitcoin i
think and some
ripple as well so basically he has a bit
everything of this
i'm pretty sure he maybe has some
ethereum as well i'm gonna show you guys
what am i viewing this but you can see
the color
so i think he is right to get these
positions
but i'm gonna go through the process of
how i come up
with this answer so very quickly market
capitalization
are much bigger for bitcoin and ethereum
around 100 and 600 billion us dollar
where we only have 5 and 10 for the
dodge and the
xrp which makes them actually a target
for those game stoppers i call them like
this those guys that are on well street
bets
so this makes those two assets possible
targets which means it can
the price can go uh you know much much
higher in a matter of few days but then
it's not easy to exit as you guys m
maybe saw
on gamestop or amc so then i want to
show you guys
how i build up my views so first i look
at the chart all right
so this is the chart of the uh of the
ripple
uh since the beginning so i see
and i try to understand why uh the price
has for example here
gone up that high guys we're talking
here about around
one one thousand five hundred percent
right so it's like
very strong moves and i'm interested to
understand why this has happened because
guys technical analysis
basically showing you that same causes
will uh actually give you the same
consequences so if you understand why
this happened in terms of flows and in
terms of
fundamentals you might be able to
understand if this might happen again
so i do some research and i invite you
guys to use the same techniques when you
analyze an asset
you need to understand what are the big
moves and i found an article of 2018
that is uh basically explaining why this
rally is happening you can read
ripple has been conducting trials with a
number of financial institutions all
right so they're very close to financial
institutions
that try to get regulated to work with
all
uh the banks and central banks that they
need to get the coin
uh the most used one for international
transfers
so they work with american express sent
them there its price was also held by
news in december blah blah blah created
a consortium with japanese credit card
companies to utilize blockchain
so you can see that this had a very
bright future let me add
here i like to compare you know those
cons between them
it was actually the time when the
bitcoin was going
much higher guys so by the way look the
beautiful triangle that we had here
that's why technical analysis
is your survival kit guys all right this
is what you use to set up the trades
but to build up your view you need to
know about the fundamentals and to
understand the mindset
behind each move here we had this
beautiful triangle for one year and you
can see the breakout occurred here
uh one month after the bitcoin was
actually going
much much much higher the week the
bitcoin was like rallying 100
every week in this time so you can see
that there is
roughly one month's uh delay between the
bitcoin moves
and the ripple moves which is
interesting to notice but you can see
here
that then the reason why it actually
went up
is that there was a very hot interest
for all the coins which is happening
again today guys so
it's not you know for nothing i'm
telling you the story that happened
three years ago is that i think we're
going there again
and then why it went down same thing i
tried to make some research i didn't
find anything
regarding the ripple so my conclusion
was that it just went down
because there was less interest on the
bitcoin the bitcoin got destroyed here
it lost
80 percent in a matter of few months so
of course that the future of
uh cryptocurrencies was not as bright as
it was when the bitcoin was at 20 000.
so it just drove every uh all the
cryptocurrency
down and this is to me the reason why
the ripple has gone that
low in 2018 then nothing happened
for around two years and now guys
look same thing happening again but on a
different scale this time the triangle
have here
look see the small one in red now we
have a big one in green
and guys you know markets are actually
developing in fractals
so you know in every time degree you
have the same phenomenon
that uh occur so this triangle
gave us this what is this one going to
give us
i don't know i don't know but what i
know
is that it has been bridged on the
upside and look
once again guys the bitcoin is making
its rally
here october 15th of october when is
the ripple going higher the 20th of
november
one month after so it's very interesting
to notice that this one month difference
is still at play even right now so maybe
because those guys they want to be
regulated and they need
the cryptocurrencies to be hot so the
all the banks uh
want to get involved this could be a
reason i'm not sure
you know i'm not sure about all the
mechanisms but what i know is that it is
a fact it happened once it's happening
again
now we only i stay for now on the ripple
so it it uh it broke out around
so let me get rid of the bitcoin so we
can see the levels around 25
so 25 is a very nice level to buy
anytime guys because we have this
breakout
uh until 20 and on the short term you
have a support at 35
so 35 i'm a buyer 20 i'm a uh
even more buyer i don't really have a
target for this
because i need to see more but let me
just show you guys
uh this so you saw that we have the
bitcoin going up and then
the ripple so right now what is
happening on bitcoin for those who have
watched my previous videos i was
basically telling you guys
that uh on the short term i was seeing
this descending triangle
and i i was saying on instagram i said
it like many times i said it in my
videos that i did one week ago three
weeks ago
i i'm talking about this triangle and i
was saying it's gonna last around
three weeks this is what happened all
right i was saying this even before we
reached 35 000
and why i had 35 000 as a target i'm
gonna show you
show you this very soon but for now we
broke
this uh on the upside so i was saying
that you guys have a few days to buy at
32 to be three
we went there a few times now we're
going higher maybe we're gonna have one
more opportunity if you guys want to get
into this thread
stop loss below 28 roughly 28.29 but i'm
very bullish guys on this uh to me the
situation is very clear
this perfect asset for technical
analysis is just giving me perfect
signals and it's following
exactly what i'm expecting for more than
three months right now
i'm pretty convinced it's gonna go to
the next resistance level which is 55
000. so for those who haven't watched my
previous videos
i invite you to go and check it out you
can go and see my video on the breakouts
as well
that i did two or three weeks ago uh
where i explained how to trade those
breakouts
here there was a lot of you know very
easy trades to do
and i gave you uh all these trades uh on
my videos and on my
instagram here once again the way i
found my targets the way i found this
target
was just by measuring the low here the
high here
and applying it to this levels so when i
do this
then you can see guys that the fib
extension levels
are 35 000 so that's why i was uh saying
that we're going to have this
contribution around this level which
happened
guys and now i'm telling you that we're
going to the next one which is 55 000
all right so 1.618
2.618 the golden ratios guys we're going
there
and i think that the ripple is going to
follow all right
and not only the ripple i think the
ethereum so i do exactly the same thing
so a lot of you guys might tell me look
you have overhead resistance
at 1 600. true but guys
i have a very bullish signal on the
bitcoin the bitcoin is the king
all right so it's gonna drive every uh
other cryptocurrency
higher so i think we're going to break
it and we're going to go to the next fib
extension
same as i did on the bitcoin and guys
it's pretty clear
on this too we're going to uh 3 200.
so right now if i need to buy ethereum
or bitcoin i go to the ethereum all
right i take some bitcoin as well
because i have
good signals but i think there is more
upside to come on the ethereum in the
coming two months
for the ripple once again if i compare
to the bitcoin
you can see that basically except this
very rare period where you can see the
ripple trading higher than the bitcoin
which is the orange curve and the ripple
is here
all the other time guys you know it
depends when you start
you have the bitcoin that is just over
performing
you know so this is the bitcoin compared
to the uh
ripple over performing uh quite heavily
uh you know for example here it's around
two thousand percent
you know five times this one made five
hundred this one two two thousand five
hundred so five times over performing
over performing uh the ripple so
i think that the ripple might uh go
higher but ultimately bitcoin remains
the king
but the ripple is very news driven if
they manage to find some
uh agreements with banks to get
this cryptocurrency used for all the
multi-billion international transfers
and it's the fastest coin to make this
kind of transfer
then maybe they're gonna outperform the
bitcoin but
we're not there yet and last but not
least
guys you asked me about this one the
dodge coin so the dutch coin guys
you don't have that much data to make
some analysis
what you can see is that you have this
resistance
uh you had this for six months it got
broken retested we go higher
right now what is the reason we go
higher here it's the game stoppers the
guys on reddit and world should bets
they you know because like i said once
again it's a 5 billion
us dollar market capitalization so they
have enough money
when they combine it together to
actually push this price
higher this is what they did and they
still haven't taken profit yet but they
might do it soon
so careful guys i wouldn't buy it here i
would buy it definitely but
80 percent lower you know so at 0.006 i
buy it
and otherwise go to the other coins guys
this one is dodgy you know the name
just is telling you this so yeah that's
it for me i hope you guys understood
how i actually build my analysis
fundamentally technically you know i
check the charts i try to explain
uh the moves uh try to understand where
the moves are coming from
see which asset is actually leading
which one is
lagging here we have the bitcoin leading
ripple by
around one month three years ago and
here again we have these triangle
patterns that look
working very well on bitcoin on uh
repo and we have this fib extension
levels that are very well
followed on the ethereum and on the
bitcoin so guys this is a very nice
environment to do technical analysis
and i hope that i managed to show you
how i do this and if you enjoyed this
video please don't forget to hit the
like sub and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show i see you guys